i give you the example of what
washington coach ron rivera had to say
on the score in chicago yesterday
afternoon
addressing for the first time
the team name he's been available to
reporters multiple occasions no one has
ever asked him that question in
a radio interview setting he was finally
asked that question by danny parkins of
the score
and ron rivera's first reaction first
response was
that's a discussion for another time
and the hosts were confused they're like
you mean not on an afternoon radio show
in chicago or you mean not like now or
like this is the perfect time to have a
conversation we're in the midst of a
national awakening on the extent to
which
racism has been
woven into the fabric
of the united states of america since
its founding
and it's not just racism
against one class of minority it's
racism generally
and to the extent that christopher
columbus statues are coming down and the
city of columbus is thinking about
changing its name
that directly affects
and implicates and involves the question
of racism that was committed against
native americans so
if now isn't the time when is the time
really when is the time and it did
remind me a little bit
and i don't want to go apples to apples
here they are two very distinct problems
but whenever there's a mass shooting and
there's a push to do something
to alter the gun laws in a way that
would tend to
minimize the extent to which these mass
shootings happen not round up everyone's
guns but just don't sell specific types
of guns or don't sell specific types of
equipment that make it easier to kill a
lot of people in a short time frame one
of the knee-jerk reactions is now isn't
the time to have that conversation
well it is then
and it is now as it relates to the
washington name look i know that
there have been efforts to try to get
ron rivera's attention i know that there
have been people from outside of the
organization trying to talk sense into
him about this dictionary defined slur
that is the name of the team and the
knee-jerk reaction by the
team is to point to the 2016 poll from
the washington post that found 90 of
self-identifying native americans aren't
offended by the term nine percent are
that is a flawed poll you can do the
research on it one of the big criticisms
of that poll is
that there's no proof that the
self-identifying native american truly
is native american and it's one thing
for someone to say hey i'm part native
american it's another thing for a person
to be involved in a tribe to be heavily
involved in tribal activities and to see
that native american
heritage as a key part of his or her
identity and there was a study done
earlier this year that showed that the
more closely someone actually practiced
and participated in the native american
rituals and tribal activities the more
likely they are to be offended by the
term so
at least ron rivera didn't go
2016 washington post poll but it's not
encouraging that his reaction was
if not now when and the goal seems to be
to
run out the clock and get us to a point
where we're focused on something else
that is taking up our attention that is
allowing
issues like colin kaepernick's lingering
unemployment and the lingering name of
the washington franchise to just exist
in plain sight but no one will be
bothering
anyone about those issues and again
it's entirely possible
because of the things that are happening
with the pandemic
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports